- On this episode, I talk about
hiring, specialization,
and India's in this episode twice.
(hip-hop music)
You ask questions
and I answer them.
This is the #AskGaryVee Show.
Hey everybody, this is Gary Vay-ner-chuk,
and welcome to epiosde 51
of the #AskGaryVee Show.
Before I get into the show,
I want to talk about my
coming out of basketball
retirement morning
because DRock is here and so is Staphon.
They were two of the individuals
at basketball this morning at 6:30.
One thing that VaynerNation
should know is that
is that DRock is terrible
at basketball
but he is so terrible,
that I actually had to stop
him earlier this morning
and tell him how proud I was of him
because for a man to go on
the court being that terrible
and willing to continue
to try to get better,
shows a lot about how
much self esteem he has,
and he's also clearly not
terrible at what he does
and I'm just impressed with you, DRock.
People might be thinking I'm making a joke
just to razz you, I'm not.
I appreciated your tenacity.
The couple of times
you fouled me very hard
and knocked me on the ground,
you were also very kind
and asked me if I was okay
and tried to help me up.
My intuition is that
you're just a good guy,
not because of the boss dynamics,
and I'm just a very big
fan of yours DRock.
But, like, Staphon's very good.
(laughter)
I also came out guns a-blazing.
I just want the whole
VayerNation to not be confused.
If I did not come out and play well,
there would've been no
mention of basketball.
Let's get into the show.
- [Voiceover] Andrew asks, "On
your team, is it better to
have employees who're
specialized in one thing,
or people who can wear many hats?"
- Andrew, I think the answer is both work.
I think you need both in an organization
of size, but I, you know,
in a world of not trying
to be politically correct
on this show, and, like,
trying to draw some
real lines in the sand,
I'm a huge fan of jack of all trades.
Tons of people will tell you
that means you're not good
at any of them.
I don't agree.
I think I'm really (beep)
awesome at 19 different things,
and I'm watching even
the people in this room
and this room get better
at different things.
I hate when people use the excuse
of I'm great at this,
and I go deep in this
to not try to get better at other things.
So, to make a 51-49 call,
which is what this is,
which is, like, both matter,
both really do matter.
DRock's not good at basketball,
but he doesn't have to do
that for what he's doing here.
This one has a shot at being a meme.
Makes Staphon so happy.
But I won't do the DRock,
I'm gonna find something on somebody else.
I'm gonna go with having multiple skills.
I think it speaks to agility,
and I love that.
- [Voiceover] Anthony asks, "If
given an opportunity to swap
VaynerMedia for the Jets, would you,
and why or why not?
Not really, right, Gary?
- Anthony, I would switch VaynerMedia
for the New York Jets in a hot second.
Now, I would take along
all the employees and make them all work
at the New York Jets,
and I'd assume, like,
of the 500 or so peeps
that I could probably get,
like, 312 to come over.
You know, or I would just create
some weird advertising division within
the New York Jets that
allowed me to keep everybody
because I've fallen quite in love.
I'm very in love with you guys.
- Thanks, Gary.
- You're welcome.
And so, you know,
I've fallen in love with all these peeps,
but I would do it,
because I want to own the New York Jets,
and that's the bottom line.
- Gary, my name is Zac.
I'm the CEO and lead designer
here at Power Labs, which
is a website design company,
and my question for you today is:
when you're faced with two
equally qualified candidates,
how do you choose which one to hire,
assuming you only need
to hire one employee?
I'm asking because I
recently needed to hire on
a lot of new employees for 2015,
and I appreciate your answer.
Thanks, man.
- Zac, so many things are
running through my head,
all of them are gonna razz
you, which pisses me off,
because I really appreciate
you watching the show,
and you seem like an awesome dude.
A couple things.
No such thing as 'equally qualified',
make a goddamn call, right, just make one.
Number two, it seems like
you're growing pretty well.
There's a weird part of me that's trying
to tell you to hire both of them.
The only rationale is
that you can't justify
in any shape or form
within the first six months
of 2015, you needing,
there's both so narrow,
back to the last question,
great way that worked out,
that you could never see you using them,
because if you both, if you
love both of them so much,
that you should absolutely hire them both.
I'm a big fan of hiring
ahead of my growth.
A lot of people are always like,
how did you grow this so quickly?
It's because I am on the offense
and I'm hiring ahead of my growth
because I'm not worried about my margin.
I'm not hiring enough that
I couldn't make payroll
if something weird happened, you know,
and in a week I couldn't make payroll,
I'm leaving a cushion for practicality
because I'm an immigrant
and I care about people
and I wouldn't want to have layoffs,
but I'm always on the offense.
So, the two big things
that pop off for me are,
one, you know,
are you indecisive or was it, like,
the best thing to figure
out how to ask a question
for the show, or if you really mean it,
as a CEO, and, you know,
and this is where, if you're
CEO and lead designer,
you need to put your CEO hat on
and make a decision,
and then, number two,
as a CEO, you're hiring a lot of people,
there's something weird,
I can't tell you why,
but there's something weird that tells me
you should hire both.
- [Voiceover] Courtney asks,
"Does it bother your
wife that you constantly
spin your ring?"
- No.
Lizzie's way too big picture
for something as silly as that.
This is what always pisses me off, right.
You see me spinning the ring,
and you decide, not you,
but like, people decide, oh,
he must be on his fifth ring.
All my friends who never spin their ring
and are very conservative
and don't travel the world
and don't hustle 19 hours a day,
all those people, they're
on their third ring.
Me?
Right, you know, everybody talks about me
being chaotic, and all this
stuff, and I'm like chaos
and not tight and lists.
Meanwhile, I don't lost my phone,
I haven't lost my wallet,
I don't leave my bag.
Meanwhile, all these people around me,
the A-types, they've left their phone,
they've lost their things, so,
don't sleep on my carelessness
because it is dramatically smaller
than most of you think.
I could be chaos and
practical at the same time,
and that's what I am.
And, so, Lizzie isn't scared
of me spinning my ring
because I'll never lose it, got it?
- [Voiceover] Mike asks,
"How can I market a
video and rank on Google
if I do not want to utilize YouTube?
But willing to invest time and finances."
- Mike, this is an awkward question.
The first thing that pops in my mind is,
why don't you wanna use YouTube?
I'm trying to make conclusions here.
Maybe you want it to be behind a paywall
and get subscriptions?
The energy of this question is off to me.
I can't wrap my head around why you
would not want it on
YouTube in a world where,
that is so much 'by
accident' business in there,
because there's so many eyeballs
and you can SEO for it.
You're trying to SEO the video on Google
when YouTube is the
number two search engine
in the world and video
is native towards it.
Again, every spidey sense is.
Is that you wanna charge for it,
which you can still do on YouTube
and block it,
like, you know, like, block it, like,
there's, this is off, brother.
I'd love you to follow up
and give me some rationale,
because I can't find much.
Somebody help me here, is there anybody
got something for me?
- [Steve] Unless he's got some
moral objection to YouTube.
Google is the same company.
- Maybe you hate YouTube and you've got
a moral objection to YouTube,
but Google is the same
company, you're right.
I can't make this
connection point, and, boy,
all of you've watched many shows,
and many keynotes, and maybe Q and As,
and this is the one thing.
Maybe this is a catalyst
to live Q and A shows
in the future of the #AskGaryVee Show.
Maybe the people that are subscribed
to my email service should get
the only information of me
doing live Q and A shows
in 2015, maybe that was a good opportunity
to start teasing some
future opportunities.
Yeah, good show.
Dammit, god dammit.
I had such a great question.
I think of question, I'm all improv,
but I had a good one this morning.
I tried to regurgitate
it right now, it's gone.
Don't even try to find it.
It's so gone, it'll never be found.
So, question of,
question of the day.
Oh, actually, before we go
into question of the day,
I want you to show India.
India did some, a piece
of a content, show her.
So she's ready.
And then Steve, obviously,
is very involved,
and I think it's be inappropriate
to not show him as well.
One of the exciting, new things
is that garyvaynerchuck.com
is gonna start pumping
out a lot more content.
Think of me as like a news site
as a human.
So what I wanna specifically point to
is the animated gif story
from, jif story, Steve,
that I'm excited about,
and you should check that out,
and you should really, really check out
what's going on there.
I think it's, you know, a
lot of you watch my behavior,
and emulate it, smartly, good move,
and I think what we're up to there
is something worth peeking at.
Hope you join me on
Saturday, it broke my heart
that 99% of you yesterday
said you're not coming,
and I question your lack of commitment
to the VaynerNation,
especially people in, like,
Pennsylvania and Delaware and Ohio, just,
it doesn't feel that
long to take a selfie.
But, you know, you've decided that.
Question of the day, still don't have it.
India, ask it.
- What is the most amazing
holiday give you ever received?
- She's so sweet.
You keep asking questions,
I'll keep answering them.
Don't forget to subscribe
to my YouTube channel.
(hip hop music)